we could hear today from CBS chairman
and CEO Leslie Moonves for the first
time since the revelation he faces
allegations of sexual misconduct the CBS
Board of Directors announced last night
that two law firms have been hired to
carry out an independent investigation
several women accused Moonves of
inappropriate behavior between 1985 and
2006 and a Warner has new details on
this investigation and a good morning
good morning Alex Leslie Moonves
position as the top executive at CBS
hasn't changed the board of directors
says however he'll have no role in the
investigation the board announced last
night that former Securities and
Exchange Commission Chair and former
federal prosecutor Mary Jo white and
former federal prosecutor Nance let
Nancy Kassebaum
will lead a full investigation of the
allegations in recent press reports
about Moonves CBS News and cultural
issues at all levels of CBS the news
division in March hired a different law
firm to conduct an independent review
after last year's firing of CBS this
morning co-host Charlie Rose over sexual
misconduct allegations the company says
that investigation is expected to wrap
up in the coming weeks although it's
unclear how last night's announcement
could affect that this comes after six
women accused Leslie Moonves of
harassment in an article published by
The New Yorker in the report he denied
or said he did not remember many of the
claims we've since learned of an
additional sexual assault allegation
that los angeles police investigated
last year no charges were filed the
times up organization tweeted yesterday
we are watching we expect a full
transparent and expedient investigation
CBS is scheduled to report quarterly
earnings with a teleconference this
afternoon the company has not confirmed
if Moonves will